Speaker 1: So we have a new CBS News poll
asking American voters about a number of different
things, which we will look at, but one top
line that just cannot be missed is that at
this point in time, almost six months out
from the November 20, 20 election.
Seventy five percent of Trump voters still
believe Donald Trump's lie that he won the
election, not Joe Biden.
Seventy five percent of Trump voters responded
that, no, I do not consider Joe Biden the
legitimate winner of the 2020 election.
It's almost as bad with Republicans.
The idea that there's a big difference between
Republicans and Trump voters, 70 percent of
Republicans overall do not believe that Joe
Biden is the rightful winner of the 2020 election
if the numbers are anywhere close to this.
In reality, it is another humiliating embarrassment
for the country and for critical thinking
in the United States.
Now, what do I mean by if the numbers are
close to this?
In reality, it's an it's a reasonable question
to ask whether they actually believe it or
they are showing support for their tribe by
claiming to believe it, even if they don't
to send a message to the pollsters, to the
media, to Democrats, to whomever.
It's a very stupid message to send if that's
what they're doing.
But the problem is that even if they don't
actually believe it, but they just say they
do on polls, polling data like this can be
used to justify or to feign support for all
sorts of things, either by protesters or by
Republican officials.
So it's a problem.
Either way, it's certainly conceivable that
there are some people who say they don't believe
Joe Biden won, but they kind of do.
And they're just saying it for the purposes
of messing with pollsters.
Another issue we've covered how more voters
than in a long time have abandoned the Republican
Party.
The percentage of people identifying as Republican
has gone down as a result.
Does it make it more likely that the Trump
ists that stay are the ones most likely to
believe any lie that Donald Trump tells and
that this is less a shift in the Republican
Party believing this?
It's just the people that still identify are
more of the Trump wing, which is why there's
only five points of difference between Republicans
and Trump supporters in this particular case.
That may be.
On the other hand, thanks to Trump, there's
lots of previous nonvoters who join the Republican
Party.
So maybe we can't make such an assessment.
Other interesting data points from the poll.
Despite the controversy in Washington, D.C.
about infrastructure spending, it's very popular.
87 percent of the country wants to spend money
on improving roads and bridges overall.
Fifty eight percent of the country approves
of Joe Biden's infrastructure.
Big picture.
That plan includes money for roads and bridges,
but also building our green infrastructure,
hardening and improving the electrical grid,
modernizing building electric car chargers,
speeding up transitions to renewable energy,
many other great things that's popular, even
though it's not clear a single Republican
will vote for it in the House or Senate, it's
popular.
Overall, Joe Biden has very high approval
on vaccine distribution.
72 percent of the country approves of the
job Biden has done on vaccines.
Even nearly half of Republicans say Biden
has done well on vaccines, on vaccine hesitancy.
The numbers, they improved marginally since
last month in the same poll, not by much.
The number of people who are saying no to
the vaccine is steady at 22, similar to last
month, similar to other polls.
The number who are maybes went down from 22
to 18 and the number of yes, went up from
55 to 60.
Not a massive change just outside the margin
of error.
Those numbers, once we can vaccinate kids,
would get us very close if not to herd immunity.
But it would obviously be far better if we
could get the vaccine hesitancy down to 12
or 15 percent.
We have a much better chance if vaccine hesitancy
goes down to that degree.
So that's the situation.
Much of it is disturbing.
I mean, it's very disturbing, of course, that
75 percent of Trump voters now almost six
months out from the election still are saying
that Donald Trump won.
Most of those people want Trump back and would
vote for him again.
As recent polling has shown us, you also don't
get to numbers like these without big boosts
from media.
And so we have to go back to Fox News and
to Newsmax and to O.J. and and others for
boosting these conspiracies from day one after
the election, continuing to boost them until
they received lawsuit threats.
And even today, they're still hosting guests
who say this exact same stuff.
The network anchors will sort of stay silent
and play more.
Boy with it, but that's a big factor in how
people even came to believe this stuff, it's
not clear how we fix it.
Lots of the people who still think Trump won
are the same people who won't wear a mask
indoors, and they're the same people who won't
get a vaccine because they believe it's some
kind of democratic plot to destroy liberty,
even though they also believe Trump invented
the vaccine or they think the vaccine will
be used to control their minds or poison them.
That's a pretty deep you could call it a delusion
or a misunderstanding, a fact that's deep
and significant.
And I don't really know how you fix that.
And so maybe in that context, it's not super
shocking that you still see that level of
the Republican Party believing Trump didn't
really lose, Joe Biden didn't really win.
And what some of you are not going to believe
is that they are sort of going at it again
with the voter fraud stuff.
Yeah, yes, they're doing it.
Take a listen to this